[Music]
hey everyone I'm correct I'm John we're
gonna watch from Ninja Panda spider-man
and far from home
unnecessary censorship heck yeah
this is tough work to your video request
for my name Pete Dunn you know what I'm
going to change this up let's make this
is try not to laugh challenge I have a
plan okay first I mean hey uh yeah we're
just talking about the trip yeah and
Peter's what I don't okay
I don't know that all right
I think that went really great Nick
Fury's gonna superheroes I don't really
why because if you don't come knife my
life why don't you want some scares just
answer the phone I need your help MJ
watching movies of the entire time -
okay I'm sure that's nothing I saw you
at the funeral but I didn't think that
was a good time to have been really
inappropriate that's what I just said
right
I used to every day then I come back
five years later and now I nothing are
you sure you're good oh dude don't worry
seriously kidding by Nick Fury probably
the coolest thing that ever happened to
me anyway and it's pretty hard yeah we
survived this you'll have all summer to
Brad totally you but I think I just
threw up in my mouth a little
I might have a mint computermen the star
you created of a soldier from another
earth named Quentin space sponsors in
Europe is totally ridiculous
and apparently exactly the kind of thing
people who believe right now I mean
everybody bought it but these days you
can be the smartest guy in the room the
most qualified and no one cares unless
you're flying around with a cape or
shooting lasers from your no one will
even listen I'm not ready for this trip
to be over yet and I kind of want to do
something fun yes yes like you want to
go yes nice okay
awesome I'll go outside in ten minutes
five minutes five is good okay well what
about tonight you snuck off and you've
that thing I saw you well you only me
because you thought I was part of me I
[Music]
am trying to seven billion people here
and if he catches on before I him and
you put my and nobody wants in there
right yeah oh look who stereo was a
fraud but but he mean but he's no he's
been faking the whole thing was illusion
tech
it's easy to people when our yourselves
about you Brad my anything it's cool to
people in the bathroom
yeah dude what's that about no no no
like that it was uh I'm gonna be a cool
teacher right now you gotta stop doing
that okay and it's weird
no more on the bathroom you don't know
all stores hurts other people's feelings
spider-man's aunt
we knew that tacky that's accurate
statement yeah we're sharing right
seriously it's a good piece of advice I
forgot we were trying not to laugh so
I'm pretty sure I failed at the
beginning and then I recovered you
forgot I didn't know if that was a bit
or not it was established right up front
John I know I know kids and they're
raging hormones everybody wants to get
it on in Europe with spider-man I only
[ __ ] me because I'm spider is the one in
some version of this universe I could
see that conversation happening if Peter
was a little bit more player something
it's so funny you just put a bleep in
and it's amazing what can sound naughty
I didn't even get the one at the
beginning though quite naughty I thought
it was supposed to be like a dick joke
it didn't really follow in the sentence
but that was the only word that really
filled in the gap dude I think that went
really great I love the way Ninja Panda
a disease I don't know why these are so
hilarious ninja Bennett's these because
there's always some weird alternate
movie here whenever I watch them like
that like Nick Fury I used to [ __ ] every
I love how this story just revolves rum
jealousy it feels yeah like like a porno
without the porno it feels like yeah if
you cut all the sex out and just put in
scenes where everybody was dealing with
the con yeah I just feel like some weird
skinemax film you would put on and that
has like a weird pace and this ain't
spider-man do it yeah I mean the ones
would happy talking about you know MA I
mean yeah that's an accurate acceptance
that's yeah this just if Marvel was
r-rated but without the final yeah yeah
you haven't really changed the context
of the movie thinking it is what it is
yeah that was great
how much you're gonna really sadder than
like kudos on the entity it's difficult
to do this I wonder what a ninja pandas
method is to editing one of these is you
like sit down and then I imagine you
bother like watches it with subtitles
and then has to pause and write it down
pause and write down this moment and
stuff yeah or do you just like download
the movie insert it into your editing
system and just experiment as you go and
then trim it down to the funniest bits
you know yeah well the other thing too
is is in the editing especially the
sound editing one of the things that
sells these the most is picking and
choosing which words if you have like
the F sound just before the bleep it
fills it in and makes it that much more
tangible whereas if it's just a bleep
with nothing around it sometimes it's a
little harder so I always appreciate
that little extra bit of sound editing
because you had to find all these
different F words or you know like words
that start with certain letters to help
sell the net like the averted Ness of
the bleeping I mean this is simply
hysterical kudos again in Japan for
doing this you uh continue to amaze me
yeah with your simple method of bleeping
at certain words they gave us one
harvest under patreon you got to make a
movie Oh a patreon movie a whole film
yeah yeah oh that would be great that
joke probably get old much faster there
for the course of an entire film and if
it's just one or my work we need to try
it at least once I find the works
might be like a great experiment or it
could be when they go this should have
just seen a sketch on SNL you know
alright guys well if you haven't done so
already please subscribe to ninja Panda
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click our notification Belding and
notified whenever we got a youtube video
up you can check us out on patreon where
we got plenty of goodies and Pete Don
thanks for requesting this dude you're
making a lot of progress on your story
has of late she's almost done with Game
of Thrones he's finally catching up to
that show but dude I just want to say
from all our long conversations I just
want to you in the oh yeah you so hard
if I can just keep in you for a lot more
with your mother coming in the room your
dad being in the corner I just want your
parents to be there as I said my way
down your Mac and watch you just it's
gonna be a delight for everyone you